i promised when i got elected i'd always
give it to you straight from the
shoulder
the good the bad the truth
so as we head into christmas weekend i
want to answer your questions about a
rising number of coveted cases covered
19 cases
and i want to start by acknowledging how
tired
worried and frustrated i know you are
i know how you're feeling for many of
you this will be the first or even the
second christmas
where you look across the table be an
empty kitchen chair there
tens of millions have gotten sick
we've all experienced upheaval in our
lives
but while covet has been
a tough adversary we've shown that we're
tougher
tougher because we have the power of
science and vaccines
that prevent illness and save lives
and tougher because of our resolve so
that let me answer some questions
that lay uh
out the steps the vice president i are
taking to prepare for the rising number
of cases experts tell us
we can expect in the weeks ahead
first
how concerned should you be about
omicron
which is now the dominant variant in
this country and it happened so quickly
the answer is straightforward
if you're not fully vaccinated
you have good reason to be concerned
you're at a high risk of getting sick
and if you get sick you're likely to
spread it to others including friends
and family and the unvaccinated have a
significantly higher risk of ending up
in a hospital
or even dying
almost everyone who has died from
covet-19 in the past many months
has been unvaccinated
unvaccinated
but if you're wrong if you're among the
majority of americans who are fully
vaccinated and especially if you've
gotten the booster shot that third shot
you're much you have much much less
reason to worry you have a high degree
of protection against severe illness
because omicron spreads so easily
we'll see some fully vaccinated people
get coveted
potentially in large numbers
there will be positive cases in every
office even here in the white house
among the unb among the vaccinated among
the vaccinated
from from omicron
but these cases are highly unlikely to
lead to serious illness
vaccinated people who get covered
may get ill
but they're protected from severe
illness and death
that's why you should still remain
vigilant
according to our doctors
even if you're fully vaccinated you
should wear a mask when indoors in
public settings
wearing a mask provides extra protection
for you and those around you and i know
some americans are wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those you celebrate with are
vaccinated
particularly if you've gotten your
booster shot
if you are vaccinated and follow the
precautions that we all know well
you should feel comfortable celebrating
christmas and the holidays as you
planned it
you know you've done the right thing
you can enjoy the holiday season
and thanks to the progress on
vaccinations this fall
we've gone from nearly 90 million adults
in july who had not even started their
vaccination process
to fewer than 40 million today
still too many
but down from 90 to 40.
all these people who have not been
vaccinated
you have an obligation to yourselves
to your family and quite frankly i
normally get criticized for this to your
country
get vaccinated now it's free
it's convenient
i promise you it saves lives
and i honestly god believe it's your
patriotic duty
another question
folks are asking is what can you do to
make yourself and your family feel safer
and be safer
the answer is simple
get your booster shot
wear a mask
our doctors have made it clear booster
shots provide the strongest of
protection unfortunately
we still have tens of millions of people
who are eligible for the booster shot
people would have not yet gotten they've
gotten the first two shots but they've
not gotten a booster
folks
the booster shots are free
and widely available
over 60 million americans
including 62 of eligible seniors our
most vulnerable group have gotten their
booster shots
i got my booster shot
as soon as they were available and just
the other day former president trump
announced he had gotten his booster shot
it may be one of the few things he and i
agree on
people with booster shots are highly
protected
join them join us
it's been six months or more since my
second shot
if it's been six months or more for your
second shot when i got my booster you
can get yours today if you've been six
months or more since your second shot
another question that folks are asking
is are we going back to march 2020 not
just last march 2021
but march 2020 when the pandemic first
hit
and that's what i keep getting asked the
answer is absolutely no
no
here are three big differences between
then and now
one
number one the first one
more than 200 million americans have
been fully vaccinated
in march
of 2020
no one was fully vaccinated
what that means is today
as cases a case of covet 19 for fully
vaccinated and boosted person will most
likely mean no symptoms or mild ones
similar to the common respiratory
viruses
over 200 million americans should have a
peace of mind that they did not have in
march of 2020
they're protected
from hospitalization and are protected
from death
second point we're prepared today for
what's coming
in march of 2020 we were not ready
today we spock tile enough we stockpiled
enough gowns mass and ventilators to
deal with the surge of hospitalizations
among the unvaccinated
today we're ready
and as i'll explain in a few minutes
we're going to be reinforcing our
hospitals helping them
number three
we know a lot more today than we did
back in march of 2020.
for example
last year we thought the only way to
keep your children safe was to close
close our schools
today we know more and we have more
resources to keep those schools open
we you can get five to 11 year olds
vaccinated
two we didn't have until last month
today
we don't have to shut down schools
because of the case of cover 19. now for
student tests positive other students
can take the test and stay in the
classroom if they're not infected rather
than closing the whole school or having
a quarantine
we can keep our k-12 schools open
that's exactly what we should be doing
so folks let me summarize
we should all be concerned about omicron
but not panicked
if you're fully vaccinated and
especially if you got your booster shot
you are highly protected
and if you're unvaccinated
you're at a higher risk getting severely
ill from covert 19 getting hospitalized
and even dying
so the best thing to do is get fully
vaccinated and get your booster shot
and no this is not march of 2020.
200 million people are fully vaccinated
we're prepared we know more we just have
to stay focused
so that's where we stand now let me tell
you about the additional steps
i'm ordering today to take on what is
coming i know you've heard a lot of this
in the news already this morning
three weeks ago
i laid out a covet 19 action plan for
this winter
that prepared us for this moment
today
we're making the plan even stronger
first
we're setting up our vaccination and
booster efforts we're stepping it up
significantly
in the past two weeks we've seen the
highest vaccination rates since last
spring
and we aren't as vaccinated as a country
as we should be though
that's why we have added 10 000 new
vaccination sites
on top of the 80 000 sites that are
already we had we already had in place
and even more will open in january
i know there's some parts of this
country where people are very eager to
get their booster
where it's harder to get an appointment
excuse me
so starting this week
i'll be deploying hundreds more
vaccinators
and more sites to help get the booster
shots in people's arms
i've ordered fema the federal emergency
management agency to stand up new pop-up
vaccination clinics all across the
country
where you can get that booster shot
we've opened
excuse me we're open fema vaccination
sites in washington state and new mexico
recently as cases have increased
and today i'm directing fema to stand up
new sites in areas where there is a high
demand
these steps are going to help us add
more
more and more booster appointments and
over the just over the next few weeks
i also want to say a word to parents
if your children are not vaccinated
please get them vaccinated
if you're a parent understandably who
waited what to see how the first shots
went with other kids before getting your
own kid vaccinated you can stop waiting
six million children in our country ages
five to eleven are vaccinated
get your children protected today now
for those parents out there who have a
child that's too young to be vaccinated
that is under the age of five
i know this can still be a scary time
but one thing
one thing you can and must do
while we await vaccines for children
under five get yourself fully vaccinated
and boosted
as well as those around you
your children your caregivers your
siblings
it's critical to mask up in public
indoor places
we know that our youngest children
have only rarely been impacted by
serious covert case uh coven 19 cases
but they can be further predicted if
they're surrounded by vaccinated people
and again to folks who are not
vaccinated you might think you're
putting only yourself at risk
but it's your choice
your choice is not just a choice about
you it affects other people
you're putting other people at risk
your loved ones your friends neighbors
strangers you run into
and your choice can be the difference
between life or death
the longer the virus is around
the more likely variants form
that may be deadlier than the ones that
have come before
let me say again and again and again and
again
please get vaccinated
it's the only responsible thing to do
those who are not vaccinated or causing
hospitals to over run become overrun
again
i just spoke to the governor of new york
every covet 19 hospital means someone
with a heart attack cancer other serious
illness may not get that bed and that
life-saving care they need in the
hospital
look let me give it to you straight
again
omicron is serious potentially deadly
business for unvaccinated people
let me be clear
thanks to the prior administration and
our scientific community america is one
of the first countries to get the
vaccine
thanks to my administration and the hard
work of americans
we led a rollout made america among the
world leaders in getting shots and arms
but uptake slowed this summer
as vaccine resistance among some
hardened
look
the unvaccinated are responsible for
their own choices
but those choices have been fueled by
dangerous misinformation on cable tv and
social media
you know these companies and
personalities are making money
by peddling lies and allowing
misinformation that can kill their own
customers and their own supporters
it's wrong
it's immoral
i call on the purveyors of these lies
and misinformation to stop it
stop it now
one of the other things that we know
that has to be done
is more testy
because omicron spreads easily
especially among the unvaccinated it's
critically important that we know who's
infected
that means we need more testing
on that score we're now where we should
be
yes we have over 20 000 free testing
sites
yes we've used the defense production
act and spent three billion dollars
to greatly expand the number of at home
tests available for purchase online and
at your local pharmacy and yes
we made sure insurance covers the pcr
tests you get in the hospital or at your
doctor's office
but starting next month
private insurance will all will cover
also cover at home testing
so you can order a test online and get
reimbursed
we're providing access to free at-home
tests for those who may have insurance
as well may not have insurance i should
say as well
but it's not enough
we have to do more we have to do better
and we will
starting this week
the federal government will set up
emergency testing sites
in areas that need additional testing
capacity
before christmas the first several of
these federal testing sites will be up
and running in new york city
with many more to come
this free testing is going to help
reduce the waiting lines
the time you have to stand there
and sometimes it's an hour or more
we're going to continue to add federal
testing sites where needed so if you
want an immediate test
there'll be a place where you can go get
it we also need to do better with
at-home testing so i'm announcing today
the federal government will purchase
one-half billion
that's not a million billion with a b
additional at-home rapid test with
delivery starting in january
we'll be getting these tests to
americans for free
and we'll have websites where you can
get them delivered to your home
we've arranged for it to be easier for
you to find a free cova testing site
near you on google